in crypto people are going to lie to you
okay so they're going to tell you at the
top of the ball Market that this time is
different because they don't want you to
sell they're going to tell you a super
cycle is coming that is literally what
they told us in November 2021 they said
this time is different there's a super
cycle coming but a super cycle based on
what we just had unprecedented amounts
of money printing which is causing
astronomical levels of inflation and
people simply don't have money to put
into the crypto Market anymore and so
naturally the only thing that's going to
come next is a massive crash but they
didn't tell you that they told you that
it's going to continue to go up forever
why because they want you to be their
exit liquidity they want to dump on you
and so they need you to prop up the
market so that they can get out and
leave you holding the bag remember this
time is never different we have the
Bitcoin harving a 2month bull market and
you really need to get out